le second tour des élection
présidentielle entachée par un nouveau
drame alors que la population voter pour
élire son nouveau président le niger a
connu la perte d'agents électoraux et
c'est dans la région de tillabéri à
l'ouest du pays que leur véhicule a
roulé sur une mine qui venait d'être
posée le bilan humain est lourd sept
morts et trois blessés j'ai appris avec
regret et tristesse
l' attaque terroriste qui a causé la
mort de sept agents de la ceni dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions en cette
circonstance douloureuse
j'adresse mes condoléances aux familles
des victimes et souhaite un prompt
rétablissement aux blessés
cet attentat a probablement perpétré par
des djihadistes et le deuxième depuis le
coup d'envoi des élections lors du
premier tour une centaine de personnes
avaient été tuées lors de l'attaqué de
du village dans cette même région de
tillabéry et des drames qui
interviennent à un moment crucial du
pays c'est un grand choc où nous nous
tous à un moment historique dans notre
pays
historique parce que nous avons des
élections qui pour la première fois de
leur histoire depuis 60 ans qui sont que
se déroule une telle sorte qu un
président démocratiquement élu passe le
témoin à un autre président
démocratiquement élu
les résultats du second tour des
élections présidentielles au niger ne
seront connus que dans plusieurs jours
le temps que l'ensemble des bulletins de
vote soit dépouillé les électeurs
avaient le choix entre deux candidats
mohamed bazoum fidèles du président
sortant et mahamane ousmane ancien
président de la république dans les
années 90 le futur chef d'état nigérien
aura donc fort à faire dans un
territoire où l'insécurité règne
l'univers est régulièrement visée par
des groupes djihadistes affiliés à
l'état islamique à l'ouest et par boko
haram
à l'est du pays